für das Mutterland für Souveränität für
Putin steht auf der Flagge dieses Mannes
ein paar einzelne Unterstützer des
Präsidenten auf dem Roten Platz
ansonsten erinnert in Moskau nichts mehr
daran dass hier die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen massiv
verschärft waren die Wagner Söldner nur
einige hundert Kilometer vor der
russischen Hauptstadt standen aber die
Macht des Kreml scheint angekratzt das
Verteidigungsministerium hat seine
Arbeit gut gemacht aber was passiert ist
hätte wahrscheinlich verhindert werden
können wahrscheinlich verstärkten sich
die paranoiden Tendenzen der russischen
Behörden noch weiter die bereits
ziemlich ausgeprägt sind so ging er los
der Aufstand der Wagner Söldner in
Roßdorf am Don Panzer auf den Straßen
Kämpfer die bis vor kurzem wohl noch in
der Ukraine gekämpft haben plötzlich
Fechten sie für ihren Chef jeww.in einen
Machtkampf aus mit dem
Verteidigungsministerium und mit
Präsident Wladimir Putin
wir sind im Hauptquartier in Rosdorf am
Don es ist 7:30 Uhr wir haben die
Militäranlagen und den Flughafen unter
unserer Kontrolle
die ganze Stadt unter Kontrolle einer
Privatarmee pregorian kündigt an der
Wolle bis nach Moskau vorrücken dort
versucht Putin Stärke zu demonstrieren
die diesen militärischen Aufstand
vorbereitet haben haben Russland
verraten und werden dafür bestraft
wenige Stunden später sind die
wagnertruppen schon auf halbem Wege
Richtung Hauptstadt
am Abend im Staatsfernsehen plötzlich
die Meldung der belarussische Präsident
Lukaschenko habe vermittelt Putins
Drohung an die Söldner verpufft
angesichts ihrer Verdienst und
Heldentaten an der Front werden wir sie
immer respektieren sie fragen mich was
mit pregorian persönlich passieren wird
das Strafverfahren gegen ihn wird
eingestellt und der selbst wird nach
Belarus gehen
bejubelt von ihren Fans ziehen Sie ab
aus Rostock am Don Putin hat einer
schwer bewaffneten Söldnertruppe
nachgegeben in seiner Herrschaft
einmalig
normalerweise versucht Putin so etwas um
jeden Preis zu vermeiden er gibt
öffentlichem Druck niemals nach dass er
dazu gezwungen war ist ein Zeichen dafür
dass nicht alles gut ist und sich das
macht Gleichgewicht in der russischen
Regierung verändert
lässt sich beim Abzug feiern auch wenn
er nicht bis nach Moskau gekommen ist
mit seinem Aufstand hat er den System
Putin einen herben Schlag versetzt
viele Fragen also noch offen dazu gleich
auch ein Gespräch mit dem Vorsitzenden
des Auswärtigen Ausschusses zu
Vorschriften wir zu unserem
Korrespondenten Christian Selm nach
Moskau Christian noch mal einen schönen
guten Morgen Putin wollte ja
Entschlossenheit demonstrieren und
drohte den Aufständischen mit Zitat
harten Strafen jetzt kommt brigochien
und seine Kämpfer die kommen erstmal
straffrei davon wie stark ist auch
dadurch die Autorität von Putin ins
Wanken geraten
ja schönen guten Morgen erst ist ganz
klar Putin musst du dazugeständnisse
machen er hat die Aufständischen ja als
Verräter bezeichnet noch kurz vorher und
mit harten Strafen gedroht die hat es da
nicht gegeben weil es eben diesen Deal
gab zwischen dem Kreml und brigoschin
und dann klar war da klar war das
pregorien und seine Kämpfer
Straffreiheit davonkommen und das vor
dem Hintergrund und ähm ja dass man weiß
dass Putin eigentlich nichts mehr hast
als Verräter also das zeigt schon wie
groß das Zugeständnis ist und das Katzen
natürlich an seiner Autorität was das
langfristig für seine Macht Basis jetzt
heißt auch die ganzen Ereignisse vom
Wochenende das muss man sehen es gibt
einige Beobachter die sehen jetzt schon
wieder das Ende des Systems Putins
soweit würde ich jetzt noch nicht gehen
dass ich noch nicht aber ganz klar ist
seine Macht Basis angekratzt und auf
jeden Fall seine Autorität was ist dann
langfristig heißt wie gesagt müssen wir
sehen und es ist natürlich jetzt auch
spannend zu beobachten was Putin jetzt
als nächstes tut aus der Defensive
heraus können wie möglich davon ausgehen
dass seine Gegner jetzt noch mit
weiteren Repressionen rechnen müssen
sagt Christian Selm unserer kurspendent
live aus Moskau vielen Dank dafür und am
Wochenende gab es dann auch ein
Telefonat zwischen den USA Frankreich
Großbritannien und Deutschland zudem
sind die
bundestagsausschüsse für auswärtiges
unverteidigung von der Bundesregierung
über die Lage in Russland informiert
worden bei mir ist jetzt der Vorsitzende
des Auswärtigen Ausschusses Michael Roth
von der SPD schönen guten Morgen guten
Morgen Frau Hayali die US-Geheimdienste
sollen vor einer bewaffneten Operation
pregosch ins Russland gewarnt haben
hatte die Bundesregierung oder der BND
denn eigentlich auch irgendeine Ahnung
das weiß ich nicht ich wusste jedenfalls
nichts davon wurde darüber auch nicht
informiert ich habe mich nur wie viele
andere gefragt wie lange kann eigentlich
prigoshi noch diese Narrenfreiheit
nutzen er hat ja ganz offen das System
kritisiert hat sich mit dem
verteilungsminister mit dem General
angelegt und dann vor wenigen Tagen
begonnen die ganzen putinischen
Lügenmärchen zu entlarven beispielsweise
dass die Ukraine eigentlich selbst dran
schuld sei dann musste sie überfallen
weil sie eskalieren wollte und damit
wurde er natürlich zu einer immer
stärkeren unkalkulierbaren Gefahr für
das System Putin aber damit habe ich nun
auch nicht gerechnet wie wird denn diese
gesamte ich nenne es jetzt mal Aktion
weil keiner weiß was ein Putschversuch
was ein Aufstand was auch immer es
eigentlich genau war von der
Bundesregierung vom Auswärtigen Amt aber
auch von ihnen als Vorsitzender des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses beurteilt war es
wirklich ein Putschversuch war es wie
manche sagen eine Inszenierung
ich gehöre nicht zu diesem neuen mal
klugen die jetzt alles gleich zu 100
Prozent bewerten und einordnen können
aber eines ist schon klar hier hat
jemand aufs Ganze gesetzt nämlich happy
goshin ob das nun von langer Hand
vorbereitet wurde weiß ich nicht aber er
hat die Machtfrage gestellt und das ist
in einer Diktatur eigentlich etwas
völlig inakzeptabel ist ein Diktator
muss immer darauf achten dass seine
Macht niemals in Frage gestellt wird und
das macht diese Demütigung von Putin
auch so gefährlich denn ich fürchte der
Stalinismus in Russland wird jetzt
zunehmen das heißt putin wird jeden aus
dem Weg räumen der sich in den Weg
stellt wenn sie sagen er hat versucht
zumindest sie macht Fragen zu stellen
warum hat er dann nicht durchgezogen das
kann man sich ja dann auch Fragen
vermutlich hat er eingesehen dass er
nicht genügend Unterstützung hat
durch den Geheimdienst das vermuten ja
auch manche dass die auch Bescheid
wussten der russische Geheimdienst
also er hat offenkundig nicht über
genügend Masse verfügt dennoch hat er
Putins Bild in der Öffentlichkeit vor
allem mit der russischen Öffentlichkeit
erheblich angekratzt und er hat eines
gezeigt wenn der Typ also Putin so
richtig unter Druck steht wenn ihm das
Wasser bis zum Hals steht dann ist Putin
zu Zugeständnissen und Kompromissen
bereit und was bedeutet das jetzt wenn
Sie das sagen sagen sie noch mehr Waffen
noch mehr von allem an die Ukraine damit
man Putin an den Verhandlungstisch
zwingt ja das sage ich wir sind jetzt in
einem ganz entscheidenden Jahr wenn in
diesem Jahr sich die Ukraine nicht zu
befreien vermag von der russischen
Okkupation dann wird es ganz ganz schwer
und deswegen sollte gerade die NATO noch
mal ins Gespräch kommen und überlegen
wie können wir noch entschlossener noch
umfassender und vor allem auch noch
schneller die Ukraine unterstützen ich
fürchte nämlich einiges etwas Putin
braucht ja Erfolge und die braucht er
wahrscheinlich auf dem Schlachtfeld und
das heißt er wird mit noch größerer
Brutalität gegenüber der Ukraine
auftreten und das heißt wir müssen jetzt
dafür sorgen dass die Ukraine sich
wirklich bestmöglich zu verteidigen
vermag und von Russland besetztes Gebiet
befreien kann aber sagen sie erstmal
grundsätzlich wenn wir noch mal auf das
Wochenende schauen Bürgerkrieg wurde
abgewendet Gott sei Dank war im Grunde
war das schlecht gegen schlechter und
schlechter vielleicht wirklich im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
wir müssen uns natürlich darüber im
Klaren sein
putin ist kein lupenreiner Demokrat
sondern ein Diktator und da hat jemand
den Aufstand gewagt der den er selber
groß gemacht hat ein schlechter ein
Verbrecher der mit ihm groß und mächtig
geworden ist und vielleicht hat auch
brigoshin geahnt dass es mit seiner
Macht mit seiner großen Machtfülle bald
zu Ende sein wird und hat deshalb noch
mal alles auf eine Karte gesetzt
lupenreiner Demokrat ist natürlich eine
Anspielung an den ehemaligen SPD-Kanzler
Gerhard Schröder der Putin immer wieder
so besonders
sind ja ihre Worte und das Zitat gibt es
ja normal vielleicht noch mal einmal
kurz nach Bella Rose geschaut also man
wundert sich ja schon dass der dortige
Präsident
angeblich ich meine wir wissen das alle
nicht als Verhandler aufgetreten ist und
sich angeblich dort jetzt abgesetzt hat
es gibt dann auch Spekulation wiederum
alles nur ein Trick damit brigoshi im
Grunde deine Flanke eröffnet er gibt es
irgendwie Sinn
also es hat ja deutliche Worte der
Anerkennung gegeben aus dem Kreml für
Lukaschenka und das ist ja eine weitere
Demütigung für Putin denn Luca Schenker
ist nichts anderes als ein Herrscher von
Putins Gnaden er ist ein basal und das
auf einmal der Allmächtige Putin dankbar
sein muss gegenüber einer Luca Schenker
der ihm offensichtlich den Arsch
gerettet hat sehen Sie mir das so nach
das ist schon auch für einen Diktator
ein sehr weitgehendes Zugeständnis wie
es mit Henry Gosch ihn weitergeht da
möchte ich nicht spekulieren aber wenn
Herr Putin konsequent bleibt wird Herr
Pre Gosche ernsthafte Probleme bekommen
weil einen solchen Gegner dann auch in
Belarus den wird Putin nicht lange
gedulden können also ich weiß nicht ob
er das Überleben wird Klammer auf ich
wollte gerade sagen beseitigen auch das
ähminismus wir erleben den stallinismus
in Reinkultur und das wird noch
schlimmer werden
von der SPD der Vorsitzender des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit heute danke Ihnen